und wie kommt ihr sohn morgens aus dem
bett sind frühaufsteher einfach
fleißiger oder ist das biologisch ihr
habt abgestimmt viele von euch
bezeichnen sich als beulen also als
spätaufsteher und spät zu bett gehe
aber wisst ihr was dahintersteckt ist
das alles nur gewohnheit oder gibt es in
teuren genen zwingt uns die gesellschaft
vielleicht dazu gehen unsere natur zu
früh aufzustehen das klären wir jetzt
wir haben eine innere uhr nachts sind
wir müde
tagsüber sind wir wach aber nicht unser
schlafverhalten berichtet sich danach
auch andere körperfunktionen zum
beispiel ist unsere körpertemperatur
zwischen vier und sechs uhr morgens am
tiefsten und nachmittags am höchsten und
selbst wenn ich irgendwo eingesperrt bin
ohne uhr ohne regelmäßiges licht ohne
regelmäßige mahlzeiten zb in einem
schlaflabor dann läuft mein innerer
rhythmus immer noch weiter jetzt sieht
man dabei im schlaflabor dass die innere
uhr von menschen meistens nicht exakt 24
stunden lang ist 24 stunden und zehn
minuten das ist der mittelwert über
viele menschen hier seht ihr die inneren
tages längen von 129 menschen die an der
studie teilgenommen haben bei den
meisten bis sie ein paar minuten länger
als 24 stunden bei anderen ein bisschen
kürzer und bei manchen auch viel länger
oder viel kürzer so wie lange jetzt mein
innerer tag ist das liegt in unseren
genen und hier kommen wir zu die innere
uhr erstmal ganz allgemein in unseren
genen steckt informationen und diese
information kann gelesen und übersetzt
werden in der praxis heißt es dass nach
anleitung des gehens ein protein
hergestellt werden kann und dieses
protein hat dann irgendeine biologische
funktion wir haben auch gene die für
unsere innere uhr zuständig sind nennen
wir sie uhren gene und diese uhren gene
können abgelesen werden und produzieren
uhren proteine diese uhren proteine
sammeln sich zunächst einmal an
doch dann kommt es zu einer rückkopplung
die uhren proteine verhindert es dass
ihre eigenen gene weiterhin abgelesen
es werden keine proteine mehr
hergestellt und der uhren protein hafen
wird nach und nach wieder abgebaut wenn
es um ein protein weg ist kann das gehen
wieder abgelesen werden
es kann also wieder neues protein
produzieren und der ganze zyklus fängt
wieder von vorne an und das ganze dauert
eben ungefähr 24 stunden
das ist unsere innere uhr jetzt gibt es
bei verschiedenen menschen verschiedene
genetische besonderheiten die führen bei
dem einen dazu dass dieser zyklus länger
dauert bei dem anderen dazu dass er
kürzer dauert
und hier kommen wir jetzt zu all und
lärchen fangen wir an mit den lerchen
die lerchen sind die vögel die angeblich
den wurm fangen sie stehen gerne früh
auf und gehe gerne früh schlafen in
ihrer molekularen inneren uhr werden die
uhr proteine besonders schnell abgebaut
so dass ihr zyklus kürzer ist wenn der
eigene innere tag kürzer ist als 24
stunden muss man seine innere uhr jeden
tag ein bisschen nachstellen und so wird
man früher war bei den eulen ist es
genau andersrum wollen stehen die
beispiele auf sind aber auch länger wach
hier ist die in der eu länger als 24
stunden deswegen pendeln sie sich auch
später im tag ist ein sie müssen jeden
tag die uhr vorstellen so wie ich
übrigens viele von euch halten mich für
eine lerche aber nein ich bin ich bin
sowas von eule
ich weiß auch nicht warum die meile
videos immer um 36 kommen aber die frage
nach all den oder lerchen ist selten ein
entweder oder
wir haben es hier mit einem
kontinuierlichen spektrum zu tun und die
meisten menschen sind irgendwo in der
mitte
doch ist die lösung für mich und alle
anderen wollen nicht einfach nur ein
ziemlich lauter becker sorry alles nur
eine frage der disziplin klar
der wecker bringt auch jede euro aus dem
bett nur ihre innere uhr die steht
trotzdem noch auf nachts und das macht
sich bemerkbar
zum beispiel ist die
konzentrationsfähigkeit nachweislich
schlechte ja und das selbst wenn die
eule eigentlich genug geschlafen hat
zeitnot spätaufsteher sind nicht
automatisch langschläfer genauso wie
verschiedene menschen verschieden lange
innere uhren haben haben verschiedene
menschen auch verschieden lange optimale
schlafzeit
im durchschnitt braucht ein erwachsener
mensch acht stunden schlaf aber bei
manchen ist es näher bei anderen weniger
und das ist unabhängig davon ob man alle
oder lech ist allerdings kriegen eulen
tatsächlich zu wenig schlaf wenn man sie
zum frühen aufstehen zwingt denn
trotzdem wären sie erst später am tag
müde und wenn sie dann früh aufstehen
waren sie zu wenig geschlafen und je
länger man das durchzieht desto
schlimmer wird und was die folgen von
schlafentzug sind dazu hatten wir ja
auch schon ein ganzes video zusammen
eine technisch ist die zeit für ein
tutorial die innere uhr richtig stellen
alles was wir regelmäßig tun mahlzeiten
sport das alles kann als zeitgeber
dienen um die uhr wieder richtig zu
stellen am effektivsten ist aber licht
menschen die vollkommen blind sind haben
probleme ihre innere uhr an die tage
zeit anzupassen trotz regelmäßiger
schlafzeiten mahlzeiten und aktivitäten
sind sie lernen werden sie jeden tag ein
bisschen früher müde sind sie allen
jeden tag ein bisschen später deswegen
ist liegt die wichtigste stellschraube
für unsere innere uhr und das beste
licht gibt es immer noch von der sonne
freunde der sonne selbst an einem
bewölkten tag es tageslicht immer noch
zwei bis drei mal so hell die in einem
beleuchteten arbeitszimmer und in der
prallen sonne ist es etwa 130 mal heller
deswegen ist vor die tür gehen das beste
mittel um seine innere uhr zu stellen
und wie gut das funktioniert das zeigt
diese studie mit der forscher mit den
versuchsteilnehmern zelten gingen und
zwar in colorado in rocky mountains
durch nach einer woche zählten stand die
innere uhr geschlagene zwei stunden
früher als vorher beim zelten waren
jetzt die eulen immer noch eulen und die
lerchen immer noch lerchen aber der
unterschied zwischen den beiden wurde
kleiner und vor allem die eulen wurden
viel früher war alles im normalen
stadtleben jetzt scheint es unter den
freunden der sonne besonders viele all
zu geben nur das hier ist nicht
repräsentativ für die ganze bevölkerung
eine frage des alters es ist ganz
interessant wie spät unsere innere uhr
eingependelt ist das ändert sich mit dem
alter
als kind sind wir relativ früh dran so
zwischen 16 und 25 verschiebt sich das
ganze nach hinten und als erwachsene
sind wir wieder früher dran und zwar
gilt das so wohl wie eulen als auch für
lärchen und zackig unbedingt was damit
zu tun dass junge menschen gerne nachts
feiern gehen oder bis 3 uhr nachts meine
videos schauen man sieht diesen
unterschied auf der ganzen welt in allen
kulturen einschließlich der hatte die in
tansania heute noch als jäger und
sammler leben
das heißt diese jugendlichkeit die
scheint biologisch zu sein
was heißt das jetzt von der forschung
zur anwendung außerdem gründig gerade
genannt habe fordern schlaf forscher
immer wieder dass weiterführende schulen
erst um neun statt um 8 uhr anfangen
sollen
also liebe lehrerinnen und lehrer
vielleicht ist es für euch kein problem
um 8 uhr ausgeschlafen zu sein aber für
eure schüler ist es noch mitten in der
nacht
aber vergesst auch nicht in einem
gewissen rahmen könnt ihr eure uhr
verstellen und zwar am besten mit lichts
also ab in die sonne freunde der sonne
wir sehen uns in der endphase woche geht
es bei weile um burnout wenn ihr fragen
habt oder kommentare input schreibt das
alles gerne in die kommentare unter dem
hashtag burnout so kann ich das leichter
finden und so kann ich das vielleicht
ins nächste video mit einfließen lassen
und wir befinden uns immer noch in der
montags testphase das nächste woche
sehen wir uns wieder mal am montag bis
dahin weit sicher